in our lesson so far we got a basic
understanding of RNA seek now let's
conduct a simplified version of the RNA
seek using the TBI info platform note
that in this demo pipeline you are
making use of samples that were taken
from humanized mice with implanted
tumors and it consists of two breast
cancer subtypes that is estrogen
receptor positive and triple negative
our aim here is to generate gene
expression tables from the raw RNA
Secrets now let us click on start to
begin the pipeline
note that the functions of each of the
algorithms have been explained in the
pop-ups that show when you click on that
particular step so feel free to browse
through and learn at your own pace
recall that RNA seek analysis consists
of three major steps first we have the
pre-processing steps that makes use of
trimomatic
and PCR clean
then we have the bow tie2t algorithm for
mapping on the transcripts
and arson expression table for
quantifying Gene and isoform abundances
click on end to end the pipeline
with that we have built our very first
rnac pipeline using breast cancer
samples in our next video we will
discuss what are the various outputs and
how to interpret them